Speaker 1: Let's go back to the phones, which are
no longer phones, we are in the 21st century and
we take our calls via discord, you can find the
discord at David Pakman dotcom slash discord.
Just a reminder, if you want to get on in the in
the waiting lobby, it should have your name and
where you were calling from. Very, very important.
Let's go overseas and go to Diego from the United
Kingdom. You are on the air.
Speaker 6:
Diego, sorry, I thought I wouldn't have
any problems with my microlight. Hello,
David. I just wanted to ask you about in
the theme of misinformation on conspiracies.
Yes. A lot of people have talked
about, for example, nationalizing,
socializing, Google as a way of protecting
the public sphere. I know, for example,
Andrew Young talked about creating a dividend. Do
you what do you think about these kind of measures
as a way of kind of combating misinformation?
Yeah. Do you have any different proposals
that would be interesting?
Speaker 1: You are not going to
solve this issue by nationalizing a publicly
traded company like Google. I mean, listen,
if if Google were on the verge of failing and the
government bailed them out, they might have some
leverage to ask for something. But this is where
I feel like, guys, what are we talking about?
Nationalizing Google? If we want to deal with this
information, if we want to deal with the online
bullying and calls to violence, and we've got to
have companies that have clear terms of service
and they enforce them fairly and equally.
We need proper if if you want to look at
antitrust, OK, look at actually dealing with
antitrust and enforce it fairly. You've got all
these Republicans who haven't given to, you know,
what about antitrust and monopolies for 40 years
and now they only want to apply existing antitrust
law to social media companies. Hey, listen, if you
want to do that, I'm I'm open to doing that. But
you've got to enforce it seriously across industry
and in other places. And we've got to deal with
education so that people are less susceptible
to the disinformation and the nonsense to
begin with. But this is where like, no,
you're not you're just not going to nationalize
Google. It's not it's just not going to happen.
And so I worry that people get sucked down
like, oh, that sounds appealing. It's just not
happening. There's no there's no legal basis for
it. There's no political will for it. It just you
know, we've got so many other things we can do.
Speaker 6: Yeah, I would tend to agree with that.
Could I ask you about your thoughts
on wealth tax? I know I'm being a
little bit cheeky asking you two questions.
Speaker 1: No, I mean, listen, I think I think
wealth tax is an interesting idea. The point of
what so what's the problem with income taxes and
capital gains taxes? The problem is that there's
ways to avoid them and have significant growth
of wealth without any of that growth being
captured by the government. So the idea is
you put in a wealth tax. I am really skeptical
about how you enforce it. You could have
situations where people, in order to make their
wealth tax payments, actually have to sell
assets and realize gains. Now, some might say
that's the point. Get them to realize the gains.
I see it very logistically problematic, but I
think the impetus for capturing wealth growth
that really rich people keep outside of income,
it's a smart idea. It's a sensible idea. I just
don't know how you actually get it done.
Speaker 6: OK, that's very interesting.
And finally, I just wanted to say that a long
time ago you talked to someone from Argentina
about empanadas. Yes. And I just wanted to put
the Chilean perspective and say the Chilean
empanadas, that people are very good. I haven't
tried the Argentinean, so I can't see that better.
Speaker 1: Right. They are very good. Are
Chilean empanadas typically baked or fried?
Speaker 6: It depends. So the the the
baked ones are the meat ones and the
fried ones would be cheese or seafood ones.
Speaker 1: I just can't get behind a fried
empanada. I have to tell you, that's
one of the things that is that is
typical of the Argentinean empanada. I wanted oven
baked. I don't want it deep fried. I want to taste
the filling, not the oil. It
was fried in, you understand?
Speaker 6: I can I can be I can be in support
of that. Yeah. The empanadas sabino baked. So
I'm sure you'd enjoy one if you tried one.
Speaker 1: It sounds fantastic. I appreciate
the call. Thank you. All right. There we go.
There's Diego from the UK. Superstrong phone call.